willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung heute
haben wir uns das vorgenommen was mehr
die gegenwart ausstrahlt nämlich heute
geht es um
aktuelle theorien des bösen und da haben
wir uns zwei bücher wo genau
die von autorinnen geschrieben sind wir
hatten es ja bisher nur mit männlichen
bei trägern zu tun und jetzt zum schluss
kommen mal zwei philosophien zur sprache
bzw wir hatten eine arendt das war eine
ausnahme aber jetzt soll gegen ende auch
mal dafür gesorgt werden dass auch für
die so findet zum wort kommen wir haben
einmal von susan nehmen am evelin models
ort
ist die englische titel und wir haben
aber auch noch hier die deutsche
übersetzung und sie lautet ganz
interessant das böse denken eine andere
geschichte der philosophie
sie sehen der englische titel ist ein
bisschen anders also das böse im
modernen denkens und hier heißt der
titel das böse denken
und dann haben wir noch ein zweites buch
in der zweiten philosophie nämlich böses
denken von bettina erstanden das sind
gibt es eine ein verhältnis das
böse denken und böses denken ja da kann
man sich jetzt schon alle anhand des
titels überlegen worin besteht denn hier
der unterschied zwischen das böse denken
und böses denken böses denken kann
bedeuten etwas böses denken oder an
etwas böses denken es kann aber auch
bedeuten dass das denken selbst böse ist
also dass wir ihm denken selbst
unmoralisch sein können und diese these
vertritt bettina stangneth ihr deswegen
finde ich dieses buch sehr sehr spannend
wir haben verleiht fragen wie bestimmt
susan nehmen zu müssen die man es eine
amerikanische
philosophin die aber auch in berlin
wirkt die bestimmt susan nehmen das
verhältnis von geschichte und dem bösen
sie hat ja der englische titel auf der
wii will im modern fort also im modernen
denkens und wie bestimmt bettina
stangneth das akademische böse sie
spricht davon dass es auch im
akademischen also hier gerade jetzt mit
bösen dingen zu tun haben dass man damit
mit bösen dingen zu tun haben kann diese
these vertritt sie also auch die
akademie die universität das denken ist
nicht davor gefeit selbst böse zu sein
ja und dann haben wir noch eine frage
die knüpft direkt an die letzte sitzung
da mache ich dann oben rechts nachher
ein youtube-video einen link zum video
metern arendt gibt ihnen liefern
kritisiert hat eine bettina stangneth
einer ahrens theorie der banalität des
bösen
wir hatten ja gesehen dass
hannah arendt eichmann als gedankenlos
und auch irgendwie banal bezeichnet hat
und dagegen bindet sich bettina
stangneth anhand eines weiteren buches
von ihr das hat den titel eichmann vor
jerusalem und da geht es um die frage ob
man wirklich so banal war wirkte so
gedankenlos wie hannah arendt sagte oder
ob er das vielleicht nicht einfach nur
alles gespielt hat ob er da einfach nur
getäuscht hat und da gibt es eben belege
die dafür sprechen dass er doch sehr
viel mehr getäuscht hat als man glaubt
ja
nächstes susan nehmen
alle sind dieses buch schreibt das böse
ist das nicht ein thema für theologen
oder allenfalls amerikaner dieser
einwand den ich häufig höre ist zwar
verständlich aber dennoch grundfalsch
das böse
dass das böse nicht von theologen
gepachtet ist wird in diesem buch
gezeigt warum könnte es für amerikaner
ein thema seien gut weil zumindest
nordamerika aber auch in südamerika doch
die religion immer noch eine größere
rolle spielt als die mittel zumindest in
mitteleuropa und sie erinnern sich
bestimmt solche
aussagen oder wendungen wie die achse
des bösen
das waren wendungen die häufig auch im
kalten krieg
geprägt wurden hat er war natürlich den
russland mit gemeint und das wurde in
amerika häufig verwendet diese wendung
von politikern und ja sie sagt aber es
ist nichts politisches an nichts
theologisches sondern es ist ein thema
das böse was alle menschen betrifft und
ganz verschiedenen bereichen
und sie geht sogar noch weiter sagt das
problem des bösen was jetzt das problem
des bösen ist müssen wir uns auch noch
fragen sie sagt jetzt einfach mal das
problem des bösen ist die treibende
kraft des modernen ding kann es die
meisten zeitgenössischen versionen der
philosophiegeschichte werden die these
weniger falsch als für unverständlich
heißen denn gemeinhin wird das problem
des bösen ja der theologie zugeschlagen
also das problem des bösen könnte zum
beispiel sein warum gibt es überhaupt
böses warum sollte es überhaupt böses
geben was ist der grund dafür dass böse
existiert zumal dann wenn man gott
gottes existenz annimmt in der tradition
wurde so formuliert wie konnte ein
gütiger gott einen wild schaffen der so
viele unschuldige leiden sagt immanuel
kant erklärt hat gott würde wie viele
andere gegenstände der klassischen
metaphysik die grenzen der menschlichen
erkenntnis übersteigen eliminierte man
solche fragen aus der philosophie wenn
irgendetwas die philosophie auf beiden
seiten des atlantiks verbindet dann die
überzeugung seit kann sein nicht nur
philosophisch aussagen über gott
unzulässig worden sondern viele andere
begründung arten auch also das ist
natürlich wieder das theodizee problem
was jetzt
zunehmen anspricht und zum ttc problem
mit leibniz mach ich dann oben rechts
auch auf youtube und link wieder rein
zum nachschauen das wird bei leibnitz
sehr sehr ausdrücklich bedankt
ja also es ist die treibende kraft des
modernen denkens man kann sie jetzt
natürlich fragen wieso sollte das böse
das problem des bösen jetzt verstärken
als ttc warum sollte das nicht auch im
antiken lenkende rolle spielen gut wenn
jetzt wir sagen das augustinus den
willens begriff entdeckt hat den villa
entdeckt hat wie eine ahrens schreibt
dann kann man sich schon überlegen das
vielleicht durch unser verständnis von
freiheit was auch er eine neuere
entwicklung ist die gab es so noch nicht
in der antike die idee der freiheit in
anderer hinsicht aber nicht im sinne der
willensfreiheit liebe sie seit
augustinus kennen obwohl augustin ist ja
auch in der antike gelebt hat und an
maria auch oben rechts und links wenn
wir aber sagen das thema individuelle
freiheit ist ein modernes thema dann
stellt sich natürlich auch die frage wie
kommen wir dazu frei börse zu handeln
das könnte man auch als ein problem des
bösen an sind man könnte auch noch als
ein problem des bösen anziehen wir
können überhaupt das böse verstehen er
hat das böse über hauptgründe warum tun
wir überhaupt das böse wenn doch böse
handelt völlig sinnlos ist und ganz viel
leid erzeugte das sind also auch fragen
die man als das problem des bösen
bezeichnen könnte also deswegen ich
würde sagen es gibt nicht das problem
des bösen sondern es gibt nur probleme
des bösen dass wir mal so ein kleiner
einwand gegen niemand man kann das so
generell nicht sagen das problem des
bösen lässt sich sowohl technologisch
als auch säkular formulieren doch im
grunde geht es darum die welt als ganzes
zu verstehen daher gehört das wieder zu
ethik noch zur metaphysik es bildet
vielmehr das band zwischen den beiden
also so ist niemand versteht das problem
des bösen als die tatsache dass in der
welt einfach böses vorkommt und dass wir
das böse einfach nicht verstehen warum
gibt es überhaupt das böse das ist doch
völlig sinnlose wohl aus theologischer
perspektive wenn es gott gibt warum
sollte dann das böse existiert als auch
aus individueller perspektive wenn wir
doch einsehen dass das böse böse ist
warum tun wir dann immer wieder das böse
warum lernen wenig dass wir das böse
lassen sollten so könnte man vielleicht
das problem des bösen beschreiben
und sie sagt jetzt es gehört wieder zur
ethik also der frage was wir tun sollen
noch zur metaphysik metaphysik ist die
frage warum
konnte im gott das böse zu lassen also
theologie und metallphysik interessant
sagt es verbindet die beiden bereiche
dem würde ich zustimmen aus einem ganz
anderen grund weil ja auch das thema
freiheit zur metaphysik gehört und das
böse hängt ja ganz eng mit unserer
freiheit zusammen insofern könnte man
auch sagen ethik und metaphysik hängen
dadurch miteinander im problem des wir
sind zusammen weil es um die freiheit
geht wie immer aus freier entscheidung
das böse tun das sagte auch augustinus
und
jetzt kommt eine these von susan nehmen
das vorher waren historische these also
ich sag das böse ist bestimmend für das
moderne denken und jetzt hat sie eine
systematische these da ich es für
unmöglich halte wesenhaft die
eigenschaften des bösen zu definieren
interessiert es mich mehr was das böse
uns antut etwas als böse zu bezeichnen
ist eine weise die tatsache zum ausdruck
bringen dass es unser vertrauen in die
welt erschüttert und es ist diese
wirkung mehr als die ursache die ich
untersuchen möchte mir geht es darum
gehe darum herauszufinden was
veränderungen hinsichtlich der art und
weise wie wir das problem des bösen
verstehen uns über die veränderung
bezüge selbstverständnisses und unseres
wort gottes in der welt enthüllen es ist
nehmen möchte nichts ist er fragen was
das böse definiert wie das böse
philosophisch bestimmt werden kann
sondern sie geht von der
anwesens perspektive von der definitions
perspektive geht sie über zur wirkung
perspektive des bösen sie fragt sich was
passiert mit uns wenn wir den bösen
ausgesetzt sind was passiert damit
das ist also eine ganz andere
perspektive
und sie sagt es passiert etwas nämlich
unser vertrauen in die welt wird
erschüttert sagt sie ja also das böse
ist nicht irgendwie nur sowas kleines
was damals passiert sind das böse durch
das böse gibt es ein riss in der welt
könnte man sagen dadurch wird irgendwo
unter urvertrauen in die welt und das
ist wieder auch die metaphysik die wird
dadurch im zerstört finde ich eine ganz
interessante perspektive häufig fragt
man ja immer auch nur von der
täterperspektive aus ja also was hat
diese person für gründe das böse zu tun
und sie wendet jetzt im blick vom täter
von der täterin auf opfer und fragt was
passiert mit dem opfer wenn das böse
passiert ja und sie hatten auch ein paar
konkrete beispiele auf die wir gleich
noch eingehen werden nämlich dass eltern
elfter september aber erst mal sagt sie
die heutigen möglichkeiten bedrohend
selbst die früh neue zeitlichen
bemühungen das moralische vom
natürlichen bösen zu unterscheiden
jetzt kommt terroristische attentate
armen die willkürlichen schläge der
natur nach gehen sie mit der bewussten
reproduktion der übelsten zeiten der
natur wie etwas solchen einher wird die
mischung von moralischen und natürlichen
bösen durch die terroristen so
entsetzlich dass wir zum verzweifeln
verurteilte scheinen hier wird jetzt
angesprochen die unterscheidung zwischen
dem moralischen bösen dem mann um moral
und dem natürlichen bösen mahlung
physikum was sie da augustinus schon für
das moralische größe ist also eine
behandlung wenn zb eine person gestohlen
wird wenn sie gefoltert wird und so
weiter das ist das moralisch böse und
das natürliche böse ist wie wir gesehen
hatten wenn die natur eine katastrophe
hat wenn wir krank werden und so weiter
und so fort also natürliche übel und sie
sagt jetzt die terroristischen attentate
die sie dringend etwas neues ins spiel
terroristische attentate sorgen dafür
dass die beiden formen des bösen das
moralische und das natürliche böse immer
mehr verschwinden also das böse wird
nach nehmen selbst zu einem natürlichen
bösen durch terroristen zb warum weil
wir dadurch fast schon so ein eindruck
haben wie eine naturkatastrophe
das böse war es zb elfter september
passiert ist und dieses dieser dieser
zerstörung die war so gewaltig dass man
davon hätte ausgehen könntest wer auch
ein erdbeben gewesen auch ein erdbeben
hätte so ein großes gebäude nur
kollabieren lassen können oder ein
meteoriteneinschlag also das ist ihre
these des böse des verschwimmt immer
mehr das moderne böse das moralische
böse mit naturkatastrophen nichts
entsetzt am elfter september so sehr wie
die tatsache dass die passagiere der ins
world trade center einschlagenden
flugzeugen nicht nur aus dem leben in
den tod gerissen wurden sondern auch
noch teil der explosionen waren die
tausende andere töteten also explosionen
das ist natürlich auch was irgendwie
natürlich wirkt und vulkanausbruch oder
wie ich schon sagte meteoriteneinschlag
die wurden also da selbst teil einer
einer vom menschen verursachten
naturkatastrophen könnte man sagen also
hier ist jedenfalls das katastrophale
für sie ganz wichtig diese extremen
auswirkungen die erschüttert sind ja und
jetzt komme ich nachdem ich jetzt kurz
so ist niemand diese vorgestellt habe
kommen jetzt auf bettina stange zu
sprechen bettina stangneth hat dieses
buch geschrieben böses denken und wie
ich schon sagte bedeutet böses denken
einmal das böse zu denken also wir
denken über das böse war oder aber auch
das denken selbst ist böse und diesen
zusammenhang hat sie auch den begriff
des akademischen bösen geprägt also das
böse was bei sehr sehr
gebildeten und vielleicht auch
intelligenten menschen vorkommen kann
also bildung und akademische
cleverness die schützen nicht der böse
zu sein gegenteil
selbst im akademischen gibt es eigene
formen des bösen und jetzt geht es
erstmal um das verhältnis zwischen team
denken und den bösen sie sagt begriffe
und dem medium das denken sind keine
harmlose freizeitbeschäftigung sondern
wirken in dem moment auf die welt in dem
sich menschen mit ihrer hilfe
orientieren und nach ihren vorstellungen
arten darum ist es unsere aufgabe immer
wieder unsere werkzeuge des begreifens
zu überprüfen und zu schärfen und nicht
nur
und das nicht nur besser zu erkennen wie
wir wurden was wir sind sollen weil nur
so ein gemeinsames sprechen möglich ist
insbesondere über das was uns
verunsichert nicht als
geschichtsschreibung auch nicht als
mentalitätsgeschichte sind als versuch
die unklarheit unsere erwartungen in uns
und
miteinander nicht noch durch unscharfe
begriffe zusätzlich zu verwirren
begriffe sind wie schlüssel zu türen und
wer sich die eigene erfahrung und die
probleme seiner zeit aufschließen will
muss nicht immer wieder neue fragen
welche schlüssel in welcher schloss
passten auch die räume benennen die uns
noch ganz verschlossen sind die methode
das herauszufinden ist in der
wissenschaft zeit daher dieselbe man
fängt mit den vertrauten anschaut wie
weit man damit kommt als begriffe sagt
sie unser denken sind keine harmlose
freizeitbeschäftigung
sondern sie sind performativ sie wirken
sich auf die welt aus
und deswegen kann begreifen mit sinne
von begriffen auch als handlung
verstanden werden so wie wir begriffe
prägen so tun wir auch was und das was
wir tun kann gut oder böse sein und
jetzt geht es um das akademische böse
sagt dass die ästhetisierung als
ästhetisch machen von denken und denker
gehört deshalb zum akademischen bösen
weil sie eine gewählte haltung ist und
von dem moralischen interesse ablenkt
dass wir es nicht darin besteht das
denken als weg zur entscheidungsfindung
ernst zu nehmen diese haltung wird nicht
nur durch das selbstbewusstsein mit dem
uns der künstler entgegen tritt sondern
weil klangvolle worte und frisch erzählt
mögen auch für den zuhörer sehr viel
angenehmer sind als das ernsthafte ring
und landes relevant prinzipien der
außerdem die vielzahl möglicher
perspektiven und damit auch die
widersprüchlichkeit im vordergrund
stehen verhindert dass bewusst
eindeutige wohl eindeutig gesprächen das
erkennen des handlungsrahmens indem wir
uns notwendig orientieren müssen um
verantwortungslos zu handeln wo das
träumen im rausch der worte das wissen
über die gemeinsame welt ersetzt findet
das ding nicht mehr zu nicht mehr zur
praxis weil vernunft und auch als
betrachtung von interesse ist und damit
ihre handlungs leitende kraft verliert
der glanz des verspielten geistes ist
zwar keine faszination des bösen aber
doch die beeindruckende erscheinung eine
intelligenz die unmoralische handlung
wieder verhüten kann noch will mir
selbst die bösen handlungen und menschen
nicht mehr anders das sind vermag denn
als weiteren faszinierenden gedanken als
hier geht es um die ästhetisierung des
denkens das heißt denken wird manchmal
in manchen büchern vielleicht weil
manche denken denken zum bloßen
kunstwerk da geht es dann nur um glanz
und verfügt klangvolle worte
verführerische erzählt mögen und es geht
nicht um dasjenige was wir tun sollen
das kritisiert bettina standen an
manchen intellektuellen
leistungen da muss man sich jetzt fragen
sollte man nicht immer die freiheit
haben so zu denken und zu schreiben wie
man will es gibt auch diesen spruch die
gedanken sind frei wir sitzen damit aus
ja
also das ding ist das eine das andere
ist natürlich das schreiben also das
denken in worte fassen oder auch noch in
zeichen in büchern in medien und dass du
noch verbreiten dann würde ich schon
einmal unterscheiden aber das bloße
denken warum darf das nicht auch mal
irgendwelche
verführerischen rc bögen oder gedanken
böden
machen also das kann man sicherlich ein
bisschen kritisieren aber richtig ist in
meinen augen dass sie sagt denken ist
nicht eine harmlose
freizeitbeschäftigung
denken ist ganz wichtig denken ist eine
handlung ja denken begriffe bilden
begriffe in die welt setzen mit
begriffen die welt fassen das ist eine
handlung und je nachdem wie wir begriffe
prägen so können wir die welt verbessern
und auch verschlechtern das akademische
böse in seinen ersten beiden stoff
beschreibt eben keine unfälle
unmündigkeit die nicht selbst gewählt
wäre denken ist nicht wie stolpern wir
sind für das handeln das aus einer
bestimmten denkungsart erfolg jederzeit
verantwortlich was heißt dass wir auch
anders es auch anders machen können und
sollen finde ich auch eine gute
beschreibung denken ist nicht wie
stolpern also denken ist eine handlung
und das was also denken volk oder in
unserer denkungsart das ist sicherlich
etwas wofür verantwortlich sind denken
ist sozusagen der rahmen die
rahmenbedingung aus der dann
verschiedene handlung folgt denken
motiviert uns unsere denkungsart gibt
uns die gründe die für bestimmte
handlung oder gegen handlungen sprechen
und deswegen müssen auch die denkungsart
immer betrachten daraufhin ob sie gut
oder
ja sagt sie und die idee weiter star
idee dass es wissenschaft gibt bedeutet
ebenso wie die moral dass es etwas gibt
sodass alle geltung hat dass wir alle
geltung hat oder für niemanden die
besteigung des selber denken es unter
berufung auf den moralischen anspruch
und die damit verbundene überforderung
der urteilskraft auch ohne autorität
sichere orientierung zu liefern ist ein
akademisches böses weil es die menschen
wissenschaft und moral ihrer vollen
bedeutung
unkenntlich macht
also wir sollen sagt sie in der
wissenschaft nicht unser selber denken
über steigern obwohl doch kant gesagt
hat aufklärung ist der ausgang aus der
selbstverschuldeten unmündigkeit und wir
werden dadurch wieder mündig dass wir
selbst denken dass wir uns nicht von
anderen leuten anleiten lassen das ist
doch der kann tische gedanke ja was ist
wir können es auch übertreiben wir
können auch unser selberdenken
übertreiben indem wir denken dass wir
alle selbst erkennen könnten ja
und wir sollten uns hier immer auch in
einer beziehung sehen mit anderen
menschen und mit ihnen diskutieren und
nicht alles glauben alleine
entscheiden oder beurteilen zu können
sie spricht von einer überforderung der
urteilskraft aber wir sollten nicht
denken dass wir alles können
bei philosophen zu sehr darauf
vertrauten dass aus den bewussten
denkens immer nur das gute erwachsen
kann weil es die bösen denkwege nicht
gibt sind wir oft zu blind für die
gefahr die sich aus demselben denkt
entwickeln kann wir haben gesehen was
konsequentes denken angerichtet hat
nämlich bei einig man es war ja ein
konsequentes denken und dennoch bisher
die auseinandersetzung damit vermieden
weil es uns schwerfällt anerkennt was
doch unübersehbar ist auch mörder könnt
denken und einige für ihnen taten und
tun es schneller konsequente und
virtuose als wir es uns vorstellen kann
das ist jetzt natürlich eine kritik
gegen hannah arendt ist innern sich noch
am abend hatte gesagt eichmann war ein
gedankenloser täter und sie sagt jetzt
bettina standen ein
denken kann sehr konsequent sein und aus
dem denken kann auch böse folgen auch
mörder können denken und zwar auch sehr
gut denken sonst könnten sie gar nicht
so viel böses tun
das ist jetzt so die kritik am
hannah arendt gewesen wie ich finde es
jetzt zu treffen das war es jetzt auch
mit der
geschichte des bösen und guten man muss
natürlich auch immer noch das gute noch
ein bisschen hin zu denken ja also wir
sind jetzt hier eigentlich zu einem
abschluss gekommen so dass in den
nächsten 17 eine abschlussdiskussion
machen können ich will noch ein wort
sagen zum guten wir haben in diesem
seminar nicht nur das böse obwohl das
böse sicherlich die meisten raum
eingenommen hat wir wollen aber auch
noch mal überlegen könnte es nicht auch
das akademische gegeben dass akademisch
böse haben wir gesehen dass besteht
darin dass man alleine denken will dass
man sich nicht an die anderen
wissenschaften hält das man vielleicht
dass er auf den stil achtet und nur sehr
sehr ästhetisch schreiben möchte wie
sieht's denn aus mit dem akademisch
guten ja das wär dann eben das gegenteil
also nicht immer glauben alles alleine
machen zu können sollen eben auch mit
anderen diskutieren und sich auch mal
wieder legen lassen und eine andere
punkt eben nicht nur für die kunst
schreiben nicht nur für das eigene
publikum schreiben sondern auch so
schreiben dass es andere verstehen
vielleicht auch leute die nicht vom fach
sind die nicht an der universität sind
nicht im akademischen bereich sind was
so genanntes populärwissenschaftliches
schreiben und immer schauen dass die
gedanken die man denkt und die begriffe
die man projekt das die auch nicht so
sind dass aus ihnen etwas böses
entstehen kann eine denkungsart
entwickeln die nicht ideologisch ist wir
hatten darüber diskutiert die offen ist
korrigiert zu werden die sich nicht
immunisiert und die sich auch nicht
radikalisiert und die auch nicht
unterscheidet zwischen den guten und den
bösen sind die sich immer auch belehren
lässt das wäre vielleicht eine theorie
dass akademisch guten ja dann bedanke
ich mich für die aufmerksamkeit und bin
schon gespannt auf die diskussion gerne
auch dann im anschluss unter dem video
auf youtube